hello thian family I'm Jill morone we
just welcome you to another thian today
Bible
Q&A that's right this is the program
where we take your Bible questions and
they're answered by our 3bn family here
I love this program because we get to
open up the word of God we can study to
show ourselves approved unto God a
Workman that needs not be ashamed
rightly dividing the word of Truth we
thank you for sending in your questions
no question is too insignificant or even
too difficult because the word of God is
inexhaustible and and when we ask for
the infilling and anointing of the Holy
Spirit he comes and teaches us want to
introduce our family here right now to
my right Pastor John deny so glad you're
here Pastor Johnny thank you it's a
blessing to be here and it's always a
joy to read God's word study God's word
and ask for the lord to bless us with
the Holy Spirit to understand it amen
now coming around the table it might
look like oh wait a minute we got a
guest remote here but Pastor James
raferty Is With Us Praise the Lord for
technology where we can connect this way
you can be at your place and still
connect with us so Pastor James so glad
you're here I'm delighted to be here
Jill and with you also Pastor deny
looking forward to our program today
lots of good questions amen speaking of
good questions want to encourage you to
send in your questions for a future
Bible Q&A program we want to answer them
on an upcoming program program so you
can send those questions in several ways
you can text them pick up your cell
phone and text them to 618 228
3975 that number is 618 228 3975 you can
go to Instagram three bands Instagram
handle is 3abn uncore official and you
can send us your questions that way or
you can email us that email address is
Bible QA 3abn.org
qa3
abn.com
program before we go any further and
actually jump into the questions we want
to go to the Lord in prayer and Pastor
Johnny would you pray for us yes let's
go to the Lord in
prayer Our loving Heavenly Father we
come before you in the name of our Lord
and Savior Jesus Christ and we thank you
for the holy scriptures that are able to
make us wise unto salvation and we pray
for your Holy Spirit to give us the
understanding and the words that need to
be spoken for you know your children and
the needs they have so we pray that they
will hear a word from your throne of
grace words that will lead them to walk
closer with you and to have full
confidence in the Holy scriptures we
pray that you will continue to bless 3
AVN to reach more and more people for
you we ask for you to impress upon the
people that are are listening to us so
that they will also partake in bringing
the gospel to others we ask you in the
holy and blessed name of Jesus amen amen
amen we're going to come to Pastor James
rafy for the first question here this
one it doesn't say who it was sent in by
um neither does it tell us how it came
in but it's a great question based on
the 70 we time prophecy so it says can
you please explain Daniel 9: 24 to
27 Daniel 9:24-27 are probably one of
the most
critical uh Pro prophetic verses in the
Bible they're just amazing in their
focus and their understanding the the
four verses uh verses 24 25 26 and 27
offer a prophetic picture of a series of
events that relate first of all to the
Messiah and secondly to the Jewish
temple and each verse is going to
predict uh at his hisorical event
concerning first the Messiah and then
the temple and the outline looks like
this if you look at verse 24 it's
basically saying that Messiah is going
to finish transgression he's going to
make an end of sins he's going to make
reconciliation for iniquity he's going
to bring in Everlasting righteousness
he's going to seal up the vision and the
prophecy and he's going to anoint the
most holy and that's speaking there
about the Heavenly Temple uh in uh
Heaven that Jesus Christ Christ is now
ministering in and then if you move to
verse 25 uh you find oh and then in
verse 24 the Jerusalem Temple is going
to be given 70 weeks that is determined
for God's people that is for the Jewish
Nation to accept Jesus Christ accept the
Messiah as the one who would finish
transgression make an end of sins make a
Reconciliation for iniquity bringing
Everlasting righteousness seal up the
vision the prophecy anoint the most holy
so you've got 70 weeks determined for
the temple and the Jewish people and
then you've got
Messiah accomplishing those seven tasks
outlined in verse 24 verse 25 uh know
therefore and understand that from the
going forth of the Commandment to
restore and build Jerusalem shall be uh
unto the Messiah the prince shall be
seven weeks and two weeks that's 69
weeks 7 weeks and excuse 7 weeks and 62
weeks so that's 69 weeks so that means
Messiah is going to come before the 70
weeks ends and of course that's exactly
what happened Jesus came before the 70
weeks were up and he completed those
tasks including being taken to Heaven
resurrecting resurrected and taken to
heaven and beginning his work of
mediation in the Heavenly Sanctuary so
then you s you see in that same verse
verse 25 that the street shall be built
again and the wall even in troubless
times so we have again this dual
application first of all to Jesus and
what he would accomplish and secondly to
the temple itself and how that Temple
would be restored now this prophecy was
given to Daniel the temple had been
desolated by the Babylonians Daniel was
in captivity along with his people 70
weeks were 70 years were predicted by uh
Jeremiah of captivity until that Temple
would be restored and so from Daniel's
perspective this prophecy is speaking
about the temple being built again the
street being built again the wall even
in troubless times fulfilled uh under
Nehemiah Ezra and zerubabel those who
went back from captivity under the MEO
Persians and rebuilt the Temple then you
get to verse 26 it says there that
Messiah is going to be cut off but not
for himself so that's focusing on the
cross and that took place of course in
8031 that would be right in the middle
of the 70th week and then it says uh
concerning the Jerusalem Temple the
people of the prince who shall come
shall destroy the city and the sanctuary
and the end thereof shall be with the
flood until the end of the war
desolations are determined so that verse
is speaking about what happens to the
temple after Jesus is cut off in fact it
was 70 weeks excuse me ad70 it was uh 40
years later according to Christ uh
within a generation of time from the
time that he spoke about the destruction
of Jerusalem in Matthew 24 that that
Temple was destroyed and this prophecy
was fulfilled then verse 27 says that he
Messiah shall confirm the Covenant with
many for one week in the midst of the
week he shall cause the sacrifice and
oblation to cease and for the
overspreading of Abominations he shall
make it desolate even to the constant so
you have Christ leaving the temple in
Matthew 23 saying the house is left
desolate the whole uh Sanctuary service
was fulfilled in Christ he was the lamb
uh slain from the foundation of the
world and that Temple was to lay deser
till the very end of time and of course
it hasn't been rebuilt even to this time
so God's word is being fulfilled and
then you have the Jerusalem Temple um
being of course destroyed and that which
was determined by God is poured upon the
desolate so Messiah will take care of
our sins and transgressions and
iniquities and he will fulfill the
vision of the prophecy he will anoint
the most holy he'll be baptized with the
spirit after 69 prophetic weeks then cut
off and crucified in the middle of the
70th week um and then we have him
bringing an end to sins leaving the
Jewish temple desolate until his second
coming and the Jerusalem Temple was to
be rebuilt it took about 45 years or so
and even in difficult times and then in
the midst of the 70th week um 487 years
from 457 the temple would be made
desolate by Christ and then within a
generation 40 years that date being 78
ad it was destroyed by the Romans and
the Jewish leaders uh who refus the
significance of their Messiah uh will
not see him come again until the second
coming amen thank you so much Pastor
James there's so much in that question
and answer uh Pastor James has actually
written a book that gives more details
pertaining to this it's called the
Messiah um this is the old version the
same content inside it was just
redesigned designed the cover um so we
encourage you to contact us at 3 PN and
we would love to send you a copy so just
reach out to us and we can give you all
those details it's just called the
Messiah and it's all about the 70 we
prophecy if you look at the 70 we
prophecy the center and circumference is
really Jesus amen um so Pastor Johnny um
this has to do with Jesus this question
for you it says was Jesus
created that is a good question and this
question has been around for for a few
hundred years uh as Christians try to
understand the scriptures uh no Jesus
was not created let's take a look at
some scriptures that will help us
understand that Jesus has always existed
and if you had the capability to be able
to go into eternity past and keep going
and keep going there's not a point in
time in in the past that Jesus did not
exist Jesus has always existed uh in him
is life unborrowed original he is not
created let's go to the scriptures John
chapter 1 uh beginning verse one is the
place to start that which was from the
beginning which we have heard which we
have seen with our eyes which we have
looked upon and our hands have handled
concerning the word of life you know I'm
reading from from first John uh chapter
1 actually I need to read from John
chapter one I'm from first John in the
beginning was the word in the beginning
was the word and the Word was with God
and the word was God all things were
created by Him and by him um and by him
it says here in verse three all things
were created by through him and without
him what nothing was made that was made
and without him nothing was made that
was made so if he is created uh as some
people seem to think then this could not
be true so this is a scripture that
helps us understand that Jesus was not
created now let's take a look at
Colossians chapter 1 beginning in verse
15 he is the image of of the invisible
God the firstborn over all creation for
by him all things were created that are
in heaven that and that are on earth
visible and invisible whether Thrones or
dominions or principalities or Powers
all things were created through him and
for him and he is before all things and
in him all things consist these
scriptures are very clear to help us
understand that Jesus is not created and
again if he was created then you could
not make these statements that all
things were created by him because he
could not create himself so Jesus has
always existed he is God Eternal uh now
in in uh in in Revelation 3:14 some have
looked at this and have struggled with
what it says there let's take a look
Revelation
3:14 and to the angel of the Church of
the leodan write these things says the
amen the faithful and true witness the
beginning of the creation of God and
some people say wait wait do you see
there it says that he was the beginning
so he is the first thing that was
created not so when you look into the
Greek this word AR there that's the
beginning it is a word that signals the
originating the the one that begins the
thing so even if you look into some uh
Greek uh Aries and lexicons for example
Robertson's word picture says the
beginning of the creation of God AR not
the first of creatures as the Aryans
held in the and unitarians do now but
the originating source of creation
through whom God works so Jesus is the
originator of creation he is the one the
beginner of all creation and he is not
created uh this is something wonderful
to understand and Jesus Is Our Savior
and he is our creator and Our Redeemer
amen thank you so much Pastor Johnny
we're coming to Pastor James next this
question came in via email from John
from Kenya why does the almighty want us
to pray even though it is written that
he knows everything in our hearts before
we come before him so why do we need to
pray well that is a great question and
it is so so true that God is omniscience
he's all knowing so why do we pray uh
one of the main reasons for prayer is
really to bring our minds in harmony
with God's purposes according to Matthew
chapter 6:10 to pray that God's will
will be done in our lives as it is done
in heaven yes God knows everything he
knows our hearts but do we know
everything do we know our heart
sometimes we don't understand the Bible
says our hearts are desperately
deceitful and wicked we don't understand
our own heart so when we pray we connect
with God a way that God actually speaks
to us through the Holy Spirit and
convicts us of what's in our own Hearts
we are to pray according to Psalm 13923
and 24 search me oh God and know my
heart try me and know my ways and see if
there be any wicked way in me and Lead
Me in the way Everlast Everlasting so
prayer is an opportunity for us to
better understand our own hearts and as
we pray to God we often get clarity
about our prayers and our own heart
motive now probably one of the most
important reasons beyond that for prayer
is for forgiveness and cleansing of sin
1 John 1:9 Psalm 32: 6 uh 3-6 uh when we
kept silent uh David says my bones waxed
old through my roin all the day long for
day and night thy hand was Heavy upon me
my moisture is turned into the drought
of summer when we don't talk to God when
we don't express to God our need of
forgiveness our need of help our need of
Grace our need of Mercy our need to get
the this guilt lifted up well I can tell
you my life
was Heavy in guilt before God lifted
those burdens and God lifted those
burdens when I lifted them up to him in
prayer so prayer brings us a relief a
sense of God's forgiveness and we
acknowledge our sins to him and we find
an an expectation that he according to
his word will forgive those sins so it's
important for us to confess our
transgressions and know that he forgives
our transgressions so that's another
reason why we pray uh another third
reason why we pray is we need to pray
for other people yes God knows
everything that's going on but there are
a lot of people that may not be praying
for themselves in 1 Timothy CH 2 veres 1
and 2 Paul talks about the importance of
praying for kings and and those that are
in Authority for leaders to pray to
supplicate to intercede in their behalf
so a lot of people in this world aren't
giving a care about God and Christians
are called to fill in the Gap to pray
for other people uh to pray for apost
apostates in the church Ezra 9 Ezra
lifted up his well he was ashamed to
lift up his head to God but he prayed
for the apostasy was taking place among
his people and a great Revival came
about so a God can do a lot even in the
hearts of other people when we pray for
them and we see job every morning
praying for his family for his children
he's concerned about them have they said
something a Miss have they done
something that would bring God's
displeasure upon them and so he would
rise up early he would pray he would SA
sacrifice um and this leads us of course
to another reason for prayer and that is
for direction in life you know a lot of
times we need direction from a source
outside of ourselves Psalms 32:8 says
that God will instruct us and teach us
in the way we should go he will guide us
with his eye I love that verse it's one
that my wife and I quoted a lot when we
were dating and and getting into a
relationship together and then we also
see God's people needing to pray for
understanding biblical understanding of
Truth in Daniel chapter 10 Daniel is
fasting and praying for 3 weeks seeking
to have understand understanding of the
Bible and of course we can't leave out
Hebrews 4:15 the Bible encourages us to
come boldly to the throne of of of Grace
uh through prayer so that we can find
Grace and help in our time of need so
God does know all of our needs but often
we do not and when we pray to an all-k
knowing god we ourselves become open to
God's work in our lives prayer helps us
to see God's work to have an
appreciation and an expectation that his
promises will be fulfilled toward us and
of course we always need to pray for
others especially those who are not
praying for themselves amen thank you so
much Pastor James just want to encourage
you at home if you have not made it a
habit of prayer or a practice of prayer
I want to encourage you to try that
spend time not just in the word but in
prayer seeking God's face thank you so
much Pastor James we're coming to Pastor
Johnny next this question came from
Deborah from
Maryland does it matter if a person is
baptized just in jesus' name instead of
the Father Son and Holy Spirit is there
a correct way to be
baptized thank you very much for that
question uh the correct way is by
immersion now the question becomes is it
in the name of the father son and of the
Holy Spirit or just in jesus' name as
some people teach let's go ahead and go
to what we find in Matthew 28: 18-2
this is Jesus speaking to his disciples
and Jesus came and spoke to them saying
all authority has been given to me in
heaven and on Earth go therefore and
Make Disciples of all the nations
baptizing them in the name of the father
and of the son and of the Holy Spirit
teaching in teaching them to observe all
things that I have commanded you and lo
I Am With You Always even to the End of
the Age amen so with these words we
understand that we are to be baptized in
the name of the Father the Son and of
the Holy Spirit but we have other
scriptures and so uh people look at what
happened in the book of Acts and say
wait a minute there maybe there was a
change or something different is going
on for example in Acts chap
2:38 uh then Peter said unto them repent
and be baptized every one of you in the
name of Jesus Christ for the remission
of sins and ye shall receive the gift of
the Holy Ghost so what what is happening
here so if we didn't have the book of
Acts what would people be doing today
they would be baptizing in the name of
the father and of the Son and the Holy
Spirit so in practice it seems that okay
maybe these people were doing something
different or did God accept this baptism
only in the name of Jesus this is a
question we don't have full clarity on
but let's take a look if you take take a
look at the context of Acts chapter 2
who was Peter preaching to Peter was
preaching to Jews and at this particular
time it was a serious offense to the
scribes and the Pharisees and Sadducees
for anyone to take on the name of Jesus
Christ and to be baptized in the name of
Jesus Christ was a serious offense so
these individuals that accepted the
message it appears that they may have
been baptized in the name of Jesus but
some commentary uh com commentators say
no they were baptized according to the
way Jesus instructed in the name of the
father Son and the Holy Spirit it
doesn't say that there you might say but
Jesus instructed the disciples and we
can safely say that they followed the
instruction of Christ but but they were
preaching Jesus they were preaching the
Messiah you can look in Acts chapter 8
as well and again what is the context
preaching to people that were expecting
the Messiah the Samaritans in this case
Acts chapter 8 uh beginning in verse one
at that time a great persecution arose
against the church which was at
Jerusalem why because they were
preaching Jesus and they were all
scattered through throughout the regions
of Judea and Samaria except the apostles
and devout man carried Steven to his
burial and made great lamentation over
him as for Saul he made Havoc of the
church entering every house and dragging
off men and women committing them to
prison uh verse four there for those who
were scattered went everywhere preaching
the word then Philip went down to the
city of Samaria and preached Christ to
them why did he preach Christ to them
they were waiting for the Messiah and
then of course you go down to verse 16
and it says for as yet the whole uh for
as yet he had fallen upon none of them
talking about the Holy Spirit they had
only been baptized in the name of the
Lord Jesus so it appears that uh we
could we could look at this and say were
they being back AP ized in the name of
the Lord Jesus is that wrong uh we will
have to leave that up to God some people
feel comfortable being baptized just in
the name of Jesus but remember who is
involved in the process of our Salvation
God the Father gave the son that's right
the son gave his life for us so that we
could be forgiven and have salvation the
Holy Spirit impresses upon the hearts of
people to repent and give themselves to
the Lord so it is not wrong to be
baptized in the name of of the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit is it wrong
to be baptized in jesus' name it appears
that this may be acceptable but I would
say take this to the Lord in prayer but
the safest thing to do is to follow what
Jesus said be baptized in the name of
the father Son and the Holy Spirit in
Acts chapter 19 let's see if we can read
some of this and it happened while
Apollos was a current that Paul having
passed through the upper regions came to
Ephesus and finding some disciples he
said to them did you receive the Holy
Spirit when you believed so they said to
him we have not so much as heard whether
there is a Holy Spirit and he said to
them into what then were you baptized so
they said into John's bapt baptism then
Paul said John indeed baptized with a
baptism of repentance saying to the
people that they should believe on him
who would come after him that is on
Christ Jesus emphasis on Messiah to
accept Jesus as the Messiah was a high
offense and yes it may be for this
reason that could be that the disciples
were baptizing in jesus' name only but
it is not clear again commentators
believe that they followed the
instructions of Jesus and baptized the
name of the father Son and the Holy
Spirit but are highlighting the Messiah
as our savior thank you so much Pastor
Johnny I think in times of ignorance God
Winks right and when we come to a fuller
understanding of the godhead father Son
and Holy Holy Spirit um we be baptized
in that we're going to Pastor James next
this question came from Rhonda she lives
in Minnesota and she sent in a text
question it's about the tree of life
since we will be raised Incorruptible
and do not need to eat from the Tree of
Life to be immortal the Bible says that
we need to eat from it for the healing
of the Nations there will be many races
and cultures in heaven but why would
there be even a need for that in a
perfect Paradise so why the tree of
life that's a great question from Rhonda
thank you so much for that question um
the qu the question begs another
question that is did we need to eat of
the Tree of Life in the perfect Paradise
of Earth and just for a clarification
the Bible tells us in Revelation that
the leaves of the tree are for the
healing of the Nations but it doesn't
mention that the fruit of the tree is
for the healing of the Nations uh let's
just look at a few Bible verses now I'd
like to give you all the Bible verses
ahead of time and because I'm not sure
how much time we're going to be if we're
going to be able to get through all of
our verses in the time that we have uh
so Genesis 2:7 we're going to look at
Genesis 27 Genesis 29 Genesis 322 and 24
324 Ecclesiastes 3:20 1 Corinthians 15:
52- 55 and Revelation 21 1-5 and
Revelation 2:7 and finally revelation 22
and verse4 now we'll start in creation
God created us in Genesis 2:7 we're told
from the dust of the ground and when he
created us we were perfect sinless
beings and yet we still needed to eat of
the tree of life so God created us
perfect and sinless he created us to
live for eternity for all that death
wasn't part of the picture and yet our
lives were perpetuated according to
Genesis chapter 2 and ver9 our Eternal
lives were perpet
perpetuated um our perfect lives
were continued on not by the original
creation but by eating of the Tree of
Life access to the tree of life now we
know this this is confirmed in Genesis
3: 22- 24 because there we are told that
after we
sinned we lost access to the Tree of
Life God actually barred access to
Angels were sent there in Genesis
chapter 3 22- 24 to Bar our access and
God says lest they partake of the Tree
of Life and live forever God did not
want us to live forever anymore as
Sinners because we had sinned sin brings
death that is the consequence of sin and
so we were barred from the Tree of Life
and of course death brings the return to
the dust in Ecclesiastes 3:20 we're told
that from dust we came and to dust we
shall return so think about this it's a
it's an amazing process God creates us
to live forever he perpetuates that by
access to the Tree of Life the fruit of
the Tree of Life we sin which brings
death we are barred from the AIS of the
tree of life and we return to dust and
then God according to 1 Corinthians 15
God actually is recreating us in Christ
Jesus and he resurrects us to New Life
from the dust because from dust we came
to dust we return but when Jesus returns
all of his faithful people whove
returned to dust because when you die
your body turns returns to dust and of
course through creation we accelerate
that process God recreates us from the
dust he recreates us in a perfect
Immortal state in other words to live
forever in 1 Corinthians 15 it says this
Mortal must put on immortality and this
corruption must put on incorruption so
we're back to Garden of Eden status not
only so but we are actually returned to
the Garden of Eden in Revelation 21 1-5
we have the Garden of Eden restored to
us and it's not in heaven this time
Heaven comes down to earth in Revelation
chapter 20 one John sees the New
Jerusalem coming down to this earth and
in revelation 22 he sees the Tree of
Life revelation 22 and then we see this
admonition and this admonition is found
in a couple of places in Revelation
revelation 22 verse uh verses 1-4 but
also Revelation or verse 14 but also
Revelation 2:7 those who keep the
Commandments of God are allowed access
to the Tree of Life in other words they
are going to live forever and that life
is going to be perpetuated by eating of
the tree of life so that's the reason
why the tree of life is necessary in the
new Heaven and the new Earth so let's
just summarize this God created us to be
sin sinless beings and live forever in a
perfect paradise and since God is the
source of life he alone has immortality
that's what we're told in 1 Timothy
chapter 6 and verse 16 and that means
it's innate in himself he doesn't need
to receive it from any other outside s
source and he perpetuates that
immortality through the tree of life for
his creatures including the the angels
and and the unfallen beings they don't
have innate immortality either only God
has immortality the Bible says Jesus
then redeems us from the consequence of
sin which is death he recreates us from
the dust of the ground we're resurrected
and he reinstates us into immortality
through partaking of the tree of life
it's a beautiful picture and you might
say well I don't need to get immortality
from a tree I can God can give me
imortal ality God does give us
immortality and how he chooses to give
us immortality is up to him I'm just
thankful that we have immortality
through Jesus Christ amen thank you so
much Pastor James we're going back to
the concept of baptism Pastor Johnny
this came from Leanne from Idaho and she
sent it in Via letter so that means
there's another way you can send in your
questions you can write them and send
them to us as well we're people baptized
before John the Baptist another good
question and so thank you
uh Leanne for that question and the
answer is yes people were baptized
before John the Baptist came along let's
take examine John chapter 1 beginning in
verse 24 now those who were sent were
from the Pharisees and they asked him
saying why do why do you baptize if you
are not the Christ nor Elijah nor the
prophet John answered them saying I
baptize with water but there stands one
among you whom you do not know
it is He Who coming after me is
preferred before me whose sandal
strapped I am not worthy to loose these
things were done in be bethabara beyond
the Jordan where John was baptizing so
as you look at this you will notice that
they were not really questioning the
baptism itself they were questioning why
do you baptize why are you doing this
they weren't questioning the baptism
itself like what are you doing what is
this this is new to us explain this and
what what what does it mean no they were
questioning why are you doing this now
why are they questioning why are you
baptizing if you are not the Christ nor
Elijah nor the prophet you see the Jews
were already accustomed they're familiar
with
baptism uh Jesus says in Matthew
23:15 woe unto you scribes and Pharisees
Hypocrites for you Compass sea and land
to make one proelite and when he is made
ye make him twofold more the child of
Hell than yourselves so to make one a
prite the process included baptism so
baptism was familiar to the Jews it's
just that John was doing something
different what was different John was
baptizing everybody he was baptizing
Jews and the Jews they were familiar
with baptizing non-jews but John is
baptizing Jews and that's why they were
like shocked you're not the prophet
you're not the Messiah
why are you doing this John was
baptizing every look at Mark 1 verse 4
and 5 John did baptize in the wilderness
and preached the baptism of repentance
for the remission of sins they didn't
think they needed this they they thought
only the non-jews needed uh repentance
for the remission of sins and there went
out unto him all the land of Judea and
they of Jerusalem and were all baptized
of him in the river of Jordan confessing
their sins so the Sadducees and
Pharisees they were like shocked you're
baptizing Jews you're not supposed to do
this why are you doing this so this is
the reason why so baptism did exist
before and actually a according to
discoveries The Kuman revealed that the
right of water baptism was practiced at
the time of Jesus and at the time of the
disciples even before that uh you may
remember that the Scrolls revealed that
were found in kman revealed many things
and one of them was this the baptism was
taking place even before John the
Baptist came on the scene MH thank you
so much Pastor Johnny we're going to
stay with a water theme going back to
Pastor James but it this does not have
to do with baptism this came in from
Nathaniel via email I don't think
there's anyone who dislikes a beautiful
beach and beautiful water most people
love to swim and some love fishing and
sailing I'm very disappointed in the
scripture revelation
21:1 I saw a new Heaven and new earth
for the first heaven and first Earth had
passed away there was no more sea in
eternity why would God deprive us of
beautiful picturesque oceans do the
scriptures offer some clue as to why God
himself might not be too thrilled with
the sea Pastor
James that is such a good question
Nathaniel and I'm going to tell you
right now my wife loves the beach she
was raised in Southern California and I
like that the ocean too so let's just
begin here in answering this question
let's just begin in the beginning like
we've been doing want to go back to
Genesis let's go to Genesis CH 1 and
verse 10 God is creating this Earth in
the beginning and it says in verse 10
and God called the dry land Earth and he
GA and and gathered together the
Gathering Together of the waters he
called Seas now God in the beginning of
this creation of this world actually
separated Earth and seas he called the
dry land Earth and then the Waters that
he gathered together he called the Seas
and then notice what happens God saw
that it was good so just to dispel your
disappointment right off the bat we want
to clarify that God actually made Seas
he made oceans and he saw them and they
were good there are going to be oceans
in the new heavens and the new Earth
because we're going back to the original
creation so why would it be that in
Revelation seems that there are no more
Seas now it's important for us to
recognize that when God blesses
something it is blessed forever however
we also realize that while SE was part
of God's creation and you can also look
at this in Genesis chap 1 ver 22 that
God while uh sees were part of God's
creation a great change took place in
the amount of sea or the amount of ocean
that we were going to have on planet
Earth in comparison to the creation um
so what we need to do now is we need to
look at Genesis chapter uh 7 because
what we have here in Genesis chapter 7
is we have a great flood that came upon
the Earth so we have the beginning of
creation God made the sea he made the
Earth he separated the two great bodies
of waters it was good to God uh this was
something that God blessed and it's part
of his original creation but then as the
mankind fell as we turned away from God
we find that sin came into this planet
and as Sin came into this planet a great
change took place in the Book of Genesis
chapter 7 we find the wickedness of man
is great on the earth and God actually
calls Noah to preach for 12 120 years
and warned of a coming Flood now when we
look at the war the the warning of the
flood we recognize that this change is
going to affect this planet Earth for a
very long time even up until our time
you see before the flood God watered the
Earth through a Mist that came up from
the Earth according to Genesis CH 2
veres 4-6 but after the flood we have
The Fountains of the deep well let's
just read the verse it's in Genesis 7
and verse 11 Genesis chter 7 and verse
11 it says this in the sixth ye six
excuse me in the 600th year of Noah's
life in the 2 month the 17th day of the
month the same day where all the
fountains of the great deep broken up up
and the windows of Heaven were opened so
what we have here in Genesis 7: 11 is we
have this huge influx of water that
comes up from the deep the midst that
used to come in from the center of the
earth is now opened up and it comes up
and it floods the the whole Earth is
filled to the topmost mountain and then
we have the rains coming down from the
heavens because this uh planet was
covered with an environment an
atmosphere of vapor of water all of that
now comes down upon this Earth it floods
the Earth once the floods start receding
Noah of course is able to to come out on
dry land again but the Bible explains
this in such a way that we recognize
that there over 70% of the world's uh
Earth land is covered with water and of
course we Trace that back to the flood
but what God is saying in Revelation is
that when he makes a new heavens and a
new Earth all of that is going to be
taken away we're not going to have 70%
of the earth of the land mass covered
with water anymore more we're not going
to have these great o there's going to
be no more sea in that sense but in the
sense of God's original creation we're
definitely going to have oceans we're
definitely going to have seas we're
definitely going to have the creatures
the this the fish and the whales Etc
that were in that are in the sea so be
of good courage there's going to be
beaches in the new Heaven and the new
Earth thank you Pastor James I just
reminded in First Corinthians 2 Eye Has
Not Seen Ear Has Not Heard nor is
entered into the heart of man the things
God has prepared for those who love him
so I'm looking forward to that thank you
uh Pastor Johnny Switching gears here
this came from Kelly from Michigan it
was an Instagram question why did
Michael Saul's daughter despised King
David when she saw him
dancing that's another good question and
we want to thank Kelly for that question
uh let's go to 2 Samuel chapter 6
beginning in verse 12 to get some
context now it says now it was told King
David saying the Lord has blessed the
house of obededom and all that belongs
to him because of the Ark of God so
David went and brought up the Ark of God
from the house of obededom to the city
of David with gladness and so it was
when those bearing the Ark of the Lord
had gone six Paces that he sacrificed
oxen and fatted sheep then David danced
before the Lord with all his might and
David was wearing a linen ephod and
we'll highlight that so David and all
the house of Israel brought up the Ark
of the Lord with shouting and with the
sound of the trumpet let's go to verse
16 now as the Ark of the Lord came into
the city of David Michael Saul's
daughter looked through a window and saw
King David leaping and whirling before
the Lord and she despised him in her
heart you may remember that she was his
wife separated for a while because David
was being pursued by Saul but she was
returned to him verse 17 so they brought
up the Ark of the Lord and set it in its
place in the midst of the T Tabernacle
that David had erected for it then David
offered burnt offering and peace
offerings before the Lord verse 20 then
David returned to bless his household
and Michael the daughter of Saul came
out to meet David and said how glorious
was the King quote unquote of Israel
today uncovering himself today in the
eyes of the maids of his
servants underline that as one of the
base fellows shamelessly uncovers
himself what is going on here she is
rebuking David for being uncovered now
was he uncovered and exposing himself no
remember he was wearing a linen ephod
the priest were wearing linen ephod the
common priest would wear that and common
people would wear linen ephod as well
now what is happening is here notice the
word
gloriously and King uh being highly to
here because she had come to live in
royalty under her father Saul and she
got so accustomed to this that it was
offensive for her to see David the king
dressed like the common people he had
taken off his Royal robes and he was
dancing and gladness and praising God
and she was offended because he had
appeared as a common person so um notice
what David says so David said to Michael
it was before the Lord who chose me
instead of your father and of his house
to appoint me ruler of the people of the
Lord over Israel therefore I will play
music before the Lord and I will even be
more undignified than this and will
humble in my and will be humble in my
own sight but as for the M Servants of
whom you have spoken by them I will be
held in honor David was upholding
himself and that he recognized himself
as humble now notice that David was not
rebuked by the Lord you do not find that
but you do find that Michael was rebuked
notice verse 23 therefore Michael the
daughter of Saul had no children to the
day of her death it appears that she was
not allowed to have children because of
this incident thank you so much Pastor
Johnny pride is an Insidious thing and a
serious thing so that humility of heart
coming before him is so important Pastor
James this is your last question for
today this came from Sue from New Mexico
she sent it in via text is it true that
the 144,000 will be brought up to heaven
to get their orders then come back down
and do the work God has given them
please help me to understand
this a sue thank you so much for sending
that question and asking for help in
understanding it that is probably based
on Revelation chap 14 in verse one of
Revelation 14 it describes the 144,000
and it says that they are seen on Mount
Zion with the lamb whom they follow
wherever he goes now we want to
understand Sue that this is a faith
statement and what I mean by that is
they're not literally on Mount Zion we
find in the Bible that God's people are
in Heavenly places by faith and we can
look at a couple of verses on that first
of all let's look in
Hebrews 12: 22- 24 Hebrews 12 22- 24
here's what it says there Paul is
speaking here under inspiration he says
but you are come under Mount Zion he's
not talking about the 144,000 in
Revelation here he's talking about the
church here the Believers in his day he
says you are come under Mount Zion under
the city of the Living God to the
Heavenly Jerusalem to a numeral company
of angels to the general assembly and
Church of the firstborn which are
written in heaven and to God the judge
of all and the spirits of just men made
perfect so we find here in this context
Sue that it's by faith that we're in
Heavenly places another verse that we
want to look at is in Ephesians chapter
2 now we could read the whole section
there 1- 7 we just want to highlight the
last few verses where Paul says but God
who is rich in Mercy for his great love
wherewith he loved us even when we were
dead in trespasses and sins has
quickened us together with Christ by
Grace you're saved and has raised us up
together and made us sit together in
Heavenly places in Christ Jesus so the
Bible clearly teaches that we go to
heaven by faith to get our orders and
through the word of God and the
inspiration of the Holy Spirit God
instructs us and directs us so that we
can go out and share the gospel with
others and in this way Heavenly Heaven
actually comes down to us in a sense in
the person of the Holy Spirit through
Heavenly angels and even at times
through Jesus Christ himself in fact we
can look at a number of scriptures that
will support this uh the first one is
John chapter 14 and chapter 16 both of
those chapters talk about the work of
the Holy Spirit giving us instructions
and then we have 1 Peter 1:19 that tells
us that the Holy Spirit inspires the
word of God which gives us instructions
and then we find Hebrews chapter 1 God
speaks through the prophets and through
Jesus Christ himself that's Hebrews 1
verse1 we also find in Psalm 32:8 that
God says I will instruct you and teach
you in the way you should go I will
guide you with my eye and Acts chapter n
is the story of Saul who was at one time
well Paul who was one time Saul who
Jesus came in person to to convict and
to convert and to equip to become uh a
teacher and a preacher to the Gentiles
of the Gospel of Jesus Christ and then
finally Revelation 1:10 Jesus comes in
person to John himself on the aisle of
Patmos so no God's people don't
literally go to heaven 144,000 don't
literally Go to Heaven until the
resurrection when of course we will all
literally go to heaven and in 4,000
years in preparation for returning to
this Earth where we live for all
eternity in an earth made new thank you
again for your question thank you so
much Pastor James Pastor Johnny last one
this is about tithe this question came
in via text it says in Genesis
28:
20-22 Jacob promises a tithe to whom
would he pay it thank you so much for
that question I will go ahead and read
Genesis 28
20-22 and Jacob vowed a vow saying if
God will be with me and will keep me in
this way that I go' and I and will give
me bread to eat and rment to put on so
that I come again to my father's house
in peace then shall the Lord be my God
and this Stone which I have set for a
pillar shall be God's house and of all
that thou shalt give me I will surely
give the tenth unto thee this is the
place in the scriptures that we
understand what amount is a tithe a 10th
a uh 10% of our income this is the guide
that we have one of the places you can
go to now the question is how did he do
this and when did he do this to whom
would he pay it uh we may consider uh
Genesis 14:
18-2 as a possibility uh let's go there
and it says then mzc king of Salem
brought out Bread and Wine he was the
priest of God most high and he blessed
him and said Blessed Be Abraham of God
most high possessor of heaven and and
Earth and blessed be God most high who
ha delivered your enemies into your hand
and he gave him a tithe of all so what
did Abraham do he gave mzc tithe of all
now uh it could be that Jacob followed
this example and found a priest of God
and gave him tithe we don't have any
record of it we are not told who he paid
to who he gave the tith to and uh and
when he gave that we do not have a
record of it it but he made a vow to the
Lord and by this time Jacob had come to
such a relationship with the Lord that
he would be faithful to fulfill his vow
um now a another possibility is Genesis
chapter 35 beginning in verse one and
we'll go to verse four then Jacob then
God said to Jacob arise go up to bethl
and dwell there and make an altar there
to God who appeared to you when you fled
from the face of Esau your brother and
Jacob said to his household and to all
who were with him put away the foreign
gods that are among you purify
yourselves and change your garments then
let us arise and go up to Betto and I
will make there an altar to God who
answered me in the day of my distress
and has been with me all the way which I
have gone so they gave Jacob all the
foreign Gods which were in their hands
and the earrings which were in their
ears and Jacob hid them under the
tabarin tree which was by sheam so uh
this altar was eventually built and it
could be that at that time uh Jacob
returned the tithe to the Lord or gave
the tithe to the Lord and fulfilled his
vow we do not have record of when this
was done these are possibilities some
have even brought in the suggestion that
when Jacob uh meets his brother Esau and
gave him all the gifts that at that time
that could be the type however it was
done please understand that it was done
and if you do make a vow to the Lord the
scriptures tell us that we should ful
fulfill that vow Ecclesiastes 5:4 and 5
when you make a vow to God do not delay
to pay it for he has no pleasure in
fools pay what you have vowed better not
to vow than to Bow and not
pay thank you so much Pastor Johnny and
Pastor James thank thank you for your
study of the word of God and um the
insights that God has given you and you
can share with our 3abn family both
viewers and listeners we're going to go
to the address in just a moment for you
to send in your questions for a future
program but before we do that I'm
reminded of Psalm 51 this is David of
course after his great sin with beath
Sheba and what does he say God created
in me a clean heart renew a right Spirit
within me don't cast me away from your
presence so no matter where you are in
your journey with Jesus know that he
wants to forgive you he wants to cleanse
you he wants to restore you and he wants
to strengthen You by a spirit and
through the study of his word so send in
those
questions if you're enjoying our 3abn
Bible Q&A then tell your friends each
Monday we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA
[Music]
3abn.org 3abn Bible Q&A for answers from
God's word welcome back 3abn family
we're so glad that you've spent this
hour with us as we've opened up the word
of God and studied together I want to
give each one of our family here an
opportunity to share a closing thought
Pastor James we'll start with you well I
just want to say in closing that God's
word doesn't actually contradict itself
but how we understand God's word often
leaves contradictions our
misunderstanding can create questions
like we talked about immortality coming
at uh the resurrection or through the
Tree of Life well there's no
contradiction in those verses when you
take them all together or the sea is
there going to be no more Seas but yet
there were Seas of the beginning well we
look at the big picture and the flood is
included and we recognize again what's
taking place or for example the baptism
we talked about baptized in the name of
the Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
or baptized in the name of Jesus Christ
the lord well you can baptize people in
the name of the father and the son Jesus
Christ Our Lord and the Holy Spirit
spirit and so you have harmony with the
Bible so once we let all of inspiration
speak we get an understanding that is
biblical and we discover Perfect Harmony
in the word of God amen amen Pastor
Johnny I just want to bring out you know
the question was was Jesus created Jesus
was not created he is the Creator and I
just praise the Lord because scriptures
make this abundantly clear some have
difficulty with this and some have gone
to the length of trying to change God's
word to make Jesus a created being but
Jesus is the creator you can find this
very clearly in John 1 verse 1 2 and 3
thank you so much both of you for your
study of the word of God and your
leadership here at 3abn I'm reminded of
Jeremiah 15 the prophet says your words
were found and I ate them and your word
was to me the joy and rejoicing of my
heart we want to encourage you when you
study God's word it will become the joy
and rejoicing of your heart join Jo us
again next time on 3bn Bible Q&A
[Music]